you inducted Tupac into the Rock and
Roll Hall of Famer correct he was a
great artist and a good-looking dude to
write fly this guy really got a ton of
[ __ ] right I mean he really did can i
[ __ ] you out real quick please
one time before he was on death row
records when he was just my homeboy
after we had met at the poetic justice
rap party I was in New York and I was
doing Saturday Night Live and he was out
here and he was like what's up my [ __ ]
will you add I'm like I'm that Saturday
Night Live I'm like I ain't got no dope
that's when it was hard getting weed
over here you don't like cuz I got no
dope cause he like don't worry about a
[ __ ] thing I'm coming to
Saturday Night Live I'll be there in a
minute so he pulls up but guess what he
pulls up with who like a virgin no
kidding oh that's why she's a very first
time yeah but Johnny shows up with
Mirjana man yeah it he comes in he's got
a big bag of that do it floor he tells
her have a seat
she looks at me I look at her thing
oh wow that's Madonna back to you fog
but you let me get that dope about you
and say yeah me and we from the ride out
of here you understand me show me that
he was elevated in the game Wow
he brought Madonna defending please man
to bring me some dismal he just she was
just riding along for the ride and think
about it bringing you diz know as you
said taking him away from [ __ ]
Madonna yeah what a man that's what
that's a real brother they did I don't
know that I would do that for anybody
I'd stay home and [ __ ] Madonna I'm not
bringing I seen that with my own two
eyes and never spoke old it like I've
been holding honor this year for a long
time well quite frankly Madonna was on
the show and she talked about she talked
about being back at the side Night Live
but she talked about Tupac and the whole
deal I mean he did get down he sure did
nice clean even I arrived when she was
in love